did you see that in your father's life
and also in Johnny Cash's life but they
were both going back into their past
they were also overcoming their own need
to be seen
I suppose so I think when it comes to
this kind of pursuit of of success in
the public eye obviously we're talking
about degrees Johnny Cash was an
eminently talented singer he didn't
write half the songs people think he did
but he was most definitely reputed to
have an encyclopedic brain when it came
to music songs roots and he was destined
to do what he did and I don't think he
was doing it necessarily to seek
acceptance like to the same degree that
most people who come to Hollywood do and
the same as is more or less true of my
father my father was probably more in
search of acceptance and approval
unconsciously then then perhaps johnny
was but again not necessarily to the
degree we often see here in Hollywood
particularly on reality television I
mean there are things where people draw
the line and but certainly my father's
story is is one that's not unlike any
immigrant first born in this country who
grew up in the depression and who had to
sort of reinvent himself without
education the interesting thing about
Johnny and saw on paper they come from
completely different worlds but the
dynamic in the film is such that Johnny
is addicted to pills and my father to
the bottle and it makes for a very
interesting and compelling comparison
and contrast but they also had many
other common aspects to their background
both men grew up poor both men lost a
sibling to tragic death
both men served in the Air Force both
men were door-to-door salesman both men
auditioned to be DJs so they were very
different but they were alike also
though neither would ever admit it
that's what I found fascinating that
they did have this even though you said
in the film it was a tumultuous
relationship but in some ways they were
so different in that it seemed like
Johnny Cash sort of just just threw
things to the wind and was living on his
own terms
whereas all seems very organized and a
planner and very disciplined so do you
think that that was their pull that
underneath all of that whatever their
public facade was or who they wanted the
world to see them as that they had that
sort of same those same roots that they
were trying to sort of pull themselves
up absolutely I do believe they were
they were both trying to pull themselves
up but you make an excellent point about
the contrast of their personalities in
the sense that Johnny was pretty wild
and lived life on his own terms and soul
was as you said very organized very
serious and it's interesting a lot of
people sort of remark after seeing the
movie that they forget that it takes
more than one person to achieve success
on the order of a famous singer like
Johnny Cash that there are other people
involved in that success that don't seem
to get mentioned in the Hollywood
telling of such stories but I would say
that in a sense they were yin and yang
they were so different but their their
differences complemented one another and
together as volatile as that
relationship was their partnership their
relationship over that period of time
yielded the most remarkable things in
Johnny's career between the late 1950s
and early 1970s the interesting years if
you will so I'm not suggesting that
there wouldn't have been a Johnny Cash
flow without a soul Hall of
there's no question that together the
the the the sum was greater than they I
forget of the same goes the total was
greater than sum of its parts
something like that well there was a
great part and I and I hope this isn't a
spoiler if it is we'll take it out but
that Johnny Cash does he feel he felt
sorry for Elvis that he didn't have a
wonderful manager such as Saul Halle
because he realized that that was a huge
part of the success that was a very high
compliment from Johnny it was given to a
writer well they were doing a story on
my father so he was being quite generous
and it was nice of him to say but
certainly they were it was an
interesting story when you consider
Saul's contemporaries Colonel Tom Parker
with Elvis or Brian Epstein with the
Beatles
Saul had one important difference his
client was all but unmanageable in the
1960s so it really does make for a
fascinating story
you